I'm the doctor I can save the universe
with the kettle and some string and look
at me I'm wearing a vegetable
[Applause]
[Music]
so I did it for the last mini so I'm
gonna do it for this one cuz it might be
the best one they've done time crash and
I'll make this super quick cuz I don't
know how this episode's gonna be this is
brought to you by radio versus the
Martians it is one of the great podcasts
out there to listen to people discussing
geeky materials of all kinds whether it
is comic book superhero sci-fi fantasy
all over the place
movies TV video games Mike Gillis Casey
Dorne they are fantastic they have
amazing guests great discussions give
them a listen radio versus the Martian
is calm or wherever you happen to listen
to podcast it's good stuff
so time crash this is mm-hmm
I've realized where this doesn't happen
to me all that often but I've realized
in advance where my brain is gonna end
up taking this and some people aren't
gonna like it but we'll get there
so time crash is the little mini episode
that takes place between the last of the
Timelords and voyage of Damned
so in between those we have this little
tiny little bottle episode done with no
money using you know anything that isn't
shot in the TARDIS control room is stock
reused footage and featuring Peter
Davison returning as the fifth doctor
and this is the most I have ever liked
Peter Davison I have talked before about
my issues with him and how he's one of
my least favorite doctors but the thing
is I watched this minisode and be like
but this is gonna like him here why
doesn't he work for me elsewhere and I I
think I might figure that out but I'm
gonna I'm gonna come back to that so
it's really just a wonderful sweet
interaction between the fifth doctor and
the 10th especially with the 10th sort
of knowing and the fifth getting a
little bit flustered and frustrated
with him there their banter is bagged
worth the pain is great it's really
terrific and there's a wonderful thing
about tenants aw of Davison because
Davison was David Tennant's favorite
doctor so that whole you were my doctor
that is a meta moment where with one
actor telling another you were my doctor
and you know that's that's a really
sweet moment is it a little cheesy
well yeah but you know what it's allowed
to be it's it's a tiny little love
letter to the fifth doctor you know
noting things about him tossing out you
know companion names and you know the
fact that he went hands-free and and all
the things like that the mention of the
master the beer joke which I doesn't bug
me that much like I take it as a gag I
don't take it as like an actual
deliberate statement and if people that
like just in case the the way the joke
goes is the tenant mentions the master
Davison goes is he still have that
rubbish beard and Tennant says no no
beard well a wife so just in case you
don't know the terminology a beard is a
term occasionally used for a woman
married to a stew a gay man and that gay
the reason that gay man married a woman
was to cover the fact that he's gay to
hide behind her like she's a beard so
that relation is sometimes referred to
as a guy having a beard so yeah that's
that's what the joke is
and like I've sort of gone over it in my
head and like I don't need to like I
don't need to take that as as a direct
indication of either the master being
gay or that the doctor is you know has
any kind of issue with that if that is
the case I think
just kind of saw in his head an opening
for a joke and went there maybe I just
think that because that's something that
I tend to do there'll be times that I'll
that something will happen
and my brain will immediately go to like
some awful joke and I'll be like and
I'll say it and then immediately go I am
so sorry I had to and I I feel like it
was that mole or at least that's how I
rationalize it in my head so let's pull
it back - Davison again I've said in the
past that I thought part of the reason
why I didn't like him during his run the
show was that I didn't have the sense of
experience and his youth was working
against him now he's not the youngest I
don't think he is
the the I think Matt Smith was actually
younger but they were close at any rate
but Matt Smith worked for me because
Matt Smith still felt old whereas
Davison felt like he was playing at
being old but wasn't really convincing
me of it and I've mentioned that before
and I do think that's part of it but I
think I was over stressing that point
because as much as I you know have
enjoyed some of the Big Finish fifth
doctor stories that I've heard I don't
really love him
in them either and you need to realize
Big Finish has made me love Colin
Baker's doctor and his doctors
insufferable on the show so there has to
be something else at play here and I
think I've actually nailed down what it
is I get to see or hear the fifth doctor
have what I felt was a good dynamic or
chemistry with a companion because the
the fifth doctor went through a lot of
companions you know he he ripped through
you know he had three at a time he had
Nyssa and Tegan and Adric and then there
was Turlough and chameleon and peri like
he went through a lot and I never felt
like he had a definitive companion
cuz I feel like everybody else did you
know with Hartnell you had Susan Ian and
Barbara with trout and you had Jamie
with Pertwee you had well Joe Grant or
Sarah Jane take your pick for talk to
you you had Sarah Jane or Romana either
one works you know Sixth Doctor I mean
maybe not so much but he had enough
other problems going on that that wasn't
gonna save him anyway but him and
Perry's still kind of a thing 7th doctor
ace definitely 9th and rose 10 I mean
for me it's 10 and Donna but 10 and Rose
is still really strong too you know 11 a
me very much and I mean 12 for me it's
Bill but like I get he sunk a lot of
time into into Clara so people dig that
I'm not gonna get into 13 because I
talked about her companions before but
like five I don't feel like there's a
definitive relationship that he has with
any of these companions that is like the
quintessential darker companion
relationship of his time of his era so
the result is I I think I've come to
realize a big part of most doctors that
makes me really become endeared to them
is the relationship they have with their
companions and I don't think Davison has
I'm not gonna say he has no good
companions he doesn't have any
relationships or dynamics with his
companions that I enjoy I think in a lot
of ways I I wouldn't have fully
appreciated Colin Baker's if I hadn't
heard you know audio stories with him
with Evelyn Smythe or Frobisher because
those are fantastic campaigns that he's
got amazing chemistry with and the thing
the reason I'm bringing it up talking
about this short is because Davison has
great performance chemistry with David
Tennant I mean they're terrific together
they bounce off each other awesomely the
enthusiasms there it's just it's just
it's so it's electric and it's a feeling
I've never gotten from the guy and I was
talking
get up - just him not being very good in
the part but I'm not sure that's it I
think he just never had the right people
to play off of at least not that that he
ever had someone that he could play off
of in a way that endeared me to the guy
so I think I might have finally put the
last piece into place as to why
Davison still you know even listening to
the audio stuff and some very good ones
and taking all the stuff in this is
still my favorite instance of him by far
and I think it's the chemistry that he's
got with Tennant I think that's the
clincher so time crash which actually
did not spend all that much time talking
about because it's a short what is there
to talk about but it gave me a leaping
off point to ramble and get all the
fifth doctor fans in the room mad at me
this'll be fun what are your thoughts
not anything I just said whatever they
are jump something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
down there linked to radio versus the
Martians links to my patreon plus I got
a book social media blah blah blah all
down in the description give them a look
or you also don't have to because at the
end of the day folks I mean you're the
council I'm just running meetings until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]